مساء الخير قل ما شئت في الرئيس العراقي
الاسبق صدام
حسين لكن المؤكد تماما ان ان صدام حسين ما
زالت
اشباح تطارد العراق وتطارد العراقيين بل
تطارد كل ابناء المنطقه هناك من يعتقد ان
صدام حسين شهيد وبطل وهناك من يعتقد ان
انه سفاح وشيطان رجيم لكن في الحالتين
هناك اجماع على ان اثاره وبصماته ما زالت
في كل مكان في العراق وفي المنطقه العربيه
انا بقول الكلام ده بمناسبه ايه العراق
بتشهد حرب داروس مش موجوده بس في الفلوجه
ولا في الموصل في كل اطراف العراق وقوامها
الاساسي او الملمح الاساسي فيها وهو ده
اللي معقد كل الامور انها مش
حرب بين ابناء العراق ضد محتل خارجي مثلا
او حرب اهليه على اقليم او على بئر بترول
ولكن الملمح الاساسي فيها انها حرب طائفيه
بامتياز والحروب الطائفيه حروب خبيثه لا
تنطفئ بسهوله وت وتحتاج الى عشرات السنوات
حتى تهدئ وتنصح الامور صدام حسين اللي
اللي تم اعدامه في 30 ديسمبر 2006 مازالت
حتى الان
اثاره و طريقه اعدامه مازالت حتى الان
تخيم على المشهد في العراق انا مش هتكلم
على كل اثر صدام حسين ولا تاريخه ولا
حياته انا هاخد بس مشهد اعدامه اللي جسد
اللي كان ماستر سين او احد الذره اللي
وصلت ليها الخلافات
والعنف الطائفي صدام حسين كان ممكن كان
ممكن يتم محاكمته وكان ممكن يتم اعدامه
دون ان يترك هذا الاثر البالغ لولا البعد
الطائفي اللي حكم هذا المشهد الرهيب اللي
شافته مئات الملايين من العالم وخصوصا من
المسلمين في كل مكان في العالم المشهد كما
تذكروه وكما تتذكروه وهو متاح في كل مكان
على اليوتيوب بنجد ان صدام حسين بيدخل الى
غرفه اعدام موجود فيها واضح ان لكل اللي
موجودين فيها خصومه وواضح ان الغالبيه
العظمى كانت من تحديدا من الشيعه
العراقيين وقيل انه الامام مقتضى الصدر
كان موجودا وملثم ولست واثقا من هذه
المعلومه لكن بغض النظر اذا كان موجودا ام
غائما ام غائبا كل الهتافات
وكل السباب الذي وجه اليه وكل الادعيه
اتخذت صبغه شيعيه بحته حتى الاسامي التي
ذكرت الناس اللي كانت بتردد مقتضى مقتضى
مقتضى والناس اللي ذكرت محمد باقر الصدر
كل هذه الاسماء محمد باقر الصدر الامام او
المرجعيه الشيعيه اللي اغتالها صدام حسين
في 9 ابريل
1980 في كل الاحوال هذه الصيغه او هذه
الاجواء الطائفيه والانتقام اللي سيطرت
على رجل
بيتم بينتظر لحظاته الاخيره وفي نفس الوقت
الاتيتيود او التوجه لصدام
حسين الثبات الهدوء رفضه انه يضع قناع على
وجهه
ثباته ترديده للشهاده ادى انطباع وكانه او
ادى انطباعه بانه رئيس عراقي او زعيم
عراقي سني بين قوسين في مواجهه ميليشيا او
جماعات شيعيه منفلت بعيدا عن القانون بتح
حاول ان تنتقم من الرجل في اللحظات
الاخيره وبغض النظر عن مظالم الشيعه وبغض
النظر عن عدم انتماء صدام حسين بفكره
البعث العلماني الى جماعه دينيه محدده لكن
الصيغه اللي تم اعدامه بها كانت واحده من
الاحداث التي اشعلت وان لم تبدا الصراع
الطائفي اللي بدا اللي كان بدا من 2005 ثم
اشتد في 2006 وبعد اعدام صدام حسين وصل
الى ذره لم تشهدها هذا الصراع من قبل
اعدام صدام حسين كان له اكثر من اثر الاثر
الاولاني اشرت اليه لحضراتكم انه كان هذا
الاعدام حافز اخر لجماعات سنيه وعشائر
سنيه تعتقد انها غبنت وانها ظلمت وانه في
مد شيعي مذهبي مش ناس عاوزه تتحرر من حاكم
ظالم لا جماعات شيعيه موتوره راغبه في
السيطره على العراق وراغب مش في ازاحه
صدام راغبه في ازاحه النفوذ السني بكامله
مدعومه بالايراني و بتشجيع من الامريكان
اللي راهنوا عليهم باعتبارهم الاكثريه
فهذا اعطى شعورا بالمظلوم لدى عشائر سنيه
كثيره ده كان احد الاسباب اللي ساهمت في
اشتعال الحرب الطائفيه في العراق لكن كمان
في سعب تاني انه صدام حسين حتى قبل
ا
اعدامه كان ابتدى يراهن منذ الاجتياح
الامريكاني للعراق على جماعات مليشيات
يعني دينيه شباب من الشباب الديني يدعوك
باعتباره جماعات فدائيه دعاها الى مقاومه
العراقيين ومقاومه الايرانيين الاهم من
كده ان بعد
اغتياله مساعدو في الحزب البعث
وفي الزمره الحاكمه او الجماعه الحاكمه
للعراق راهنت ايضا على الجهاديين
والجهاديين السنه طبعا في كل مكان في
العراق ومن خارج العراق واقدر اديكم مثال
واضح مثالين واضحين جدا المثل الاولاني
عزه الدوري نائب الرئيس العراقي اللي ما
زال حتى الان لا نعلم ان كان حيا ام ميتا
ولكن عزه الدوري كان له دور مهم جدا وشديد
جدا شديد الوضوح في المقاومه ضد
الجماعات
المليشيات الشيعيه من ناحيه اللي بتمثلها
الحشد الشعبي الان وكان له دور كبير في
مساعده وان كان في رغم التوتر بينه
وبين داعش الانه ساعدها في كثير من
المواقف او على فترات كتيره ولعب دور كتير
جدا في مقاومه الحكومه المركزيه سواء
بقياده نور المالكي او الحكومه الحاليه من
خلال قيادته لايه من خلال قيادته لجماعه
رجال النقش بنديه او الجيش النقشبندي
الجيش النقشبندي دي قصه طويله تستحق منها
التوقف لاحقا عندها الما الحركه
النقشبنديه اللي هي المفروض ان هي حركه
صوفيه بدت وكانها حركه
سيديه سريه اقرب كده الى الحركات
الماسونيه اللي فيها كثير من الغموض
والالتباس لكن الراجل كان بيقود مش من بعد
سقوط صدام منذ الثمانينيات لما ابتدى
يستغل الجماعات الصوفيه في انه يعمل له
ميليشيات خاصه به تدعمه وتدعم النظام
العراقي وبدا لكنه استغل فيما بعد بعد
اغتيال صدام بعد اسف بعد اعدام صدام وبعد
دخول الامريكان العراق ابتدى يراهن عليهم
بشكل كبير جدا سواء من مخباه في العراق او
من مخباه كما قيل في سوريا وفي جبال
الاقراض ولعبت دور كبير جدا الحركه
النقشبنديه في دعم جماعات داعش وفي
الانتقام وفي مواجهه الجماعات الشيعيه وفي
مواجهه الجماعات المؤيده من جانب ايران
عندنا حاجه ثانيه مهمه جدا وكشفت عنها
مجله دير شبيجل الالمانيه من حوالي من
حوالي سنه او سنه ونص وكانت حاجه مهمه جدا
بتثبت فيها
انه مؤسس المؤسس الحقيقي لجماعه داعش هو
رجل مخابرات تابع لصدام حسين سابقا هو
الراجل اللي كان اسمه سمير محمد الخليفاوي
اللي كان مشهور باسم حج بكر الراجل اللي
تم تصفيته في العراق في سوريا في اواخر
2014 وجدوا عنده مجموعه كبيره من الاوراق
حصل بعض اعطى بعض من قتلوه هذه الاوراق
بمقابل مادي لمراسل دير شبيجل اداله 31
ورقه منها فيها تفاصيل كيفيه انشاء دوله
تنظيم
اسلامي بنفس الصيغه اللي موجود بها الان
تنظيم داعش بالتفصيل بالتفصيل بشكل مفصل
ازاي ممكن هذا التنظيم يسيطر على كامل
العراق وعلى كامل الاجزاء واجزاء واسعه من
سوريا اللي عاوز اقوله انه صدام حسين صحيح
انه تم
شنقه لكن شنقه لم يضع نهايه له ولا لنفوذه
لانه صدام حسين قل فيه ما شئت لكنه لم يكن
نبتا شيطانيا كان تع عبير عن واقع عراقي
ملتبس وشديد الصعوبه جدا لا تستطيع ان تضع
نهايه له باعدامه وبهذا الشكل اللي خد بعد
طائفي ما ادى الى ان صدام حسين يختفي
جسديا من المشهد في العراق لكن شبحه مازال
يحوم حوالين المنطقه
وحوالين وحول العراق في العراق افرز
اغتياله حرب طائفيه من غير المنتظر ان ترى
لها نهايه في المستقبل القريب وعلى مستوى
الم المطقه ادى سقوطه الى توسع النفوذ
الايراني
في بغداد في العراق وادى الى انهيار الامن
العربي تقريبا بالكامل الحقيقه انه حتى في
لما تيجي تراقب المشهد في السنوات الاخيره
بتجد ان صدام حاضر في كل الاحداث في كل
الاحداث مش بس من خلال مساعديه ولا من
خلال الحرب الطائفيه اللي بكلمكم عليها
حتى قبره الرجل اللي شيعته عانه ملايين من
الكارهين وفي نفس الوقت يعني حزن
ملايين
اخرين حزنوا عليه بنشوف ان قبره اضطرت
الحكومه العراقيه ان تغلقه في 2012 لان في
مئات بيزوره كل يعني كل
يوم فاغلق لكن ظل المكان محل اهتمام من
كثير من اتباعه ورغبه طبعا من خصومه في
التخلص منه في
2015 تم تدمير المرقد مرقده في العوجه في
تكريت وقيل انه ان اتباعه اخذوا رفاته
ووضعوها في مكان امن مين اللي دمر رفاته
قيل ان اللي دمر رفاته هي الجماعات
الشيعيه وربما يكون هي يعني داعش واتباعها
لكن في النهايه حتى روفات صدام حسين كانت
مصدر قلق كبير للحكومه
العراقيه في احدى الحلقات وصفت صدام حسين
وقلت غفر الله له فسبني بعض المتابعين من
الكويت باقضل الشتائم لمجرد ان انا قلت
غفر الله له وحين قلت في فيديو اخر ان في
رقبه صدام حسين دماء ملايين من العراقيين
وغير العراقيين عتبني البعض وقال لي كيف
تصف الشهيد صدام حسين بانه سفاح سوف يظل
صدام حسين مصدرا
للخلاف مصدرا للخلاف بين ملايين من ادباء
والملايين من كارهيه وبسبب هذا الخلاف سوف
تظل العراق للاسف لسنوات طويله في فتنه لا
منج لها الا الله سبحانه وتعالى اشكركم
الى لقاء اخر ان شاء الله